hi there welcome to today's session
we're going to talk about AWS here by
the way I'm Sam
I work as in cloud architect and
technical author with simply long
in this section we're gonna talk about
what is cloud computing and how things
were before AWS and we're going to talk
about what is AWS and the benefits of
AWS and the products and services that
amazon offers as if now and then finally
we're gonna end this session with a
project that is gonna help us understand
how to create Jenkins build server for
continuous integration and in this
project we will learn about how to
deploy and host Jenkins and open source
automation software predominantly used
for CI CD otherwise continuous
integration and continuous development
so what is cloud computing cloud
computing is the on-demand delivery of
computer resources through a cloud
platform accessed we are the internet
and it is a it's also a pay-as-you-go
Service beed compute capacity or
database or storage in cloud we access
them through the internet and that too
on a pay-as-you-go pricing model let's
talk about how things were before
AWS existed Expedia as we know as the
people logistic company or the company
that helps people move around the world
with ease has a certain problem before
they decided to migrate to AWS and
migrating to AWS was a solution to their
problem back then
booking ticket was an unpleasant
experience compared to what it is now
it generally would take a long time to
book a ticket and sometimes it would
timeout if there is a promotion or if a
huge sale announced and if the
environment is not scaled up to meet the
demand and sometimes it would timeout if
there is a promotion or if huge sale
announced and they could not scale up
the environment and keep up with the
speed of the promotion that's when they
got introduced to AWS and with the arab
lose power to increase the capacity of
the environment on the fly solved their
scaling issue instead of waiting on the
new hardware to arrive and wondering
what to do with the
where when the promotion is over with
AWS we can quickly scale up the
environment when there is a need and
scale down the environment during long
periods now that being said let's talk
about what is AWS Amazon Web Services or
in short AWS is a secure cloud service
platform offering compute power database
content delivery and other functionality
that you would need to help your
business scale and grow AWS is a very
secure cloud platform and such security
cannot be imagined in on-premises
without spending a fortune almost any
type of applications can be created and
deployed in the cloud which includes the
latest IOT applications machine learning
artificial intelligence and so on and
the best part is we can avail the
service from anywhere as long as we have
an active internet and all this is a
weld-on pay-as-you-go subscription now
let's talk about the benefits of AWS AWS
cloud platform is very easy to use one
needs no complicated programming or
compute knowledge to access and use this
environment even with less programming
and compute knowledge one could become a
probe in accessing and maintaining the
cloud the products and services offered
are very flexible in nature and that
provides room for us to easily integrate
the service to other services in AWS and
services outside interviews cloud in
general is a very reliable service and
AWS in specific is very reliable
cloud in general is very reliable and
when we talk about AWS it's very true a
statistic says that about 95% of the
cloud computing in the whole world is
run on AWS due to AWS reliable nature
their services and AWS are scalable by
nature and most of the services provide
click button scaling services and AWS
are very cost effective and it becomes
very true when you start using more
services and AWS are very cost effective
and it becomes very true when you start
using more service services and AWS are
very cost effective and it becomes more
true when we start using more since when
we start using more service the per unit
price drops down
even further security in the cloud is at
its highest with encryption and a
multi-factor authentication x' and being
able to audit the logs one can be sure
that when one hosts a service in AWS
they are hosting it in an environment
which has been built with enterprise
security in mind
all right let's now talk about our talk
briefly about the different products and
services available in the cloud some of
the products and services available in
the cloud are compute storage database
migration services networking and
content delivery developer tools and
services available for managing the AWS
environment tools needed for machine
learning development analytic tools
needed for security and identity
compliance tools needed for mobile
application services tools needed for
IOT and gaming development are some of
the products that are available in AWS
alright let's first talk about compute
service now compute service it enables
us to a develop ly run and scale our
applications and workloads on the cloud
you might agree with me that compute
service is the fundamental of any
applications and AWS provides many
options to use those computer verses in
the cloud starting from ec2 which is a
wium in the cloud do lambda which is
server less computing in the cloud to
compute service compute service also
includes container services and services
that help batch processing and deploying
applications and load balancing the
requests when we run our applications on
multiple servers and services that help
batch processing and developing
applications and load balancing the
requests when we run our applications in
multiple servers we're gonna talk about
to compute products in specific let's
talk about ec2 ec2 is a service with a
resizable compute capacity in the cloud
that allows business subscribers to run
application programs in the computing
environment and the best part here is
ec2 is resizable anytime there is more
demand I can simply resize my computer
to meet the demand on the other hand
lambda is a server less compute service
used to execute back-end codes it really
helps us to focus on the core
competencies like application building
the code let's talk about story
service for a while a Dobler storage is
known for its durability and
availability with s3 being the object
storage for the internet where users or
application can directly upload and
download the content from the internet
and EBS being a durable block storage
that gets attached to the ec2 instance
and glacier being the archival solution
in the cloud and Storage Gateway being
the Gateway for storing data locally and
having a backup in the cloud in case of
disaster let's talk about two important
storage service products in the cloud
which is s3 now s3 is an web-based cloud
storage service it's designed for online
backup and archiving of data and the
best part about s3 is that it provides
11:9 durability which means once we
stored the data in s3 the chances of
losing the data is nearly 0 eb us on the
other hand provides persistent and
resizable and migrate able storage to
the VMS or easy tools that we can run in
the cloud now let's talk about the
database offerings in the cloud
beginning with RDS for SQL and DynamoDB
for no sequel and elastic cache for web
caching services and Amazon redshift for
petabyte scale data warehousing services
database database service provides all
the database service needs we might have
let's talk about two database services
in specific RDS RDS is an web service
that is designed to simplify the set up
operation and scaling of the relational
database in the cloud and dynamodb is an
fast and flexible no sequel database
service which is well known for its low
latency and scalability performance
Network and content delivery service
contributes to the infrastructure as a
service side of the cloud it provides a
secure cloud infrastructure and connects
our physical network to our private
virtual network with low latency and
high transfer speeds and under
networking and content delivery services
we PC is virtual private cloud
networking in the cloud
route 53 is the DNS service in the cloud
and Direct Connect is a service that
connects our on-premises with AWS
environment through point-to-point cable
and CloudFront is content delivery
network or caching service throughout
the world let's talk about V PC for a
while we PC it enables us to launch AWS
resources into a virtual network that we
define in the cloud BBC resembles very
similar to our office network with
subnets firewalls private zones public
or DMZ zones and lot more we can also
create a VPN connection between on
premises and cloud environment through
this V PC and route 53 it is a scalable
and highly available domain name system
web service that helps to route the end
users to the internet application now
AWS is an domain registrar as well and
here we can buy domain names for our
organization and use them to mask the IP
addresses behind it and by the way if it
didn't know already DNS is the one that
translates human readable names like WWE
XYZ comm into the numeric IP address
let's talk about developer tool services
how developer tool services in Amazon
are provides services where developers
can store an application source code and
automatically build test and deploy
applications on AWS out of which areas
court star enables us to quickly develop
build and deploy applications in AWS and
code build is a fully managed build
service that compiles source code runs
tests and produces software packages
that are ready to deploy and code deploy
on the other hand is a service that
automatic that automates is a service
that automates software developments to
a variety of compute services including
Amazon ec2 Amazon lambda and even
instances running on-premises an AWS
core pipeline is a continuous
integration and continuous delivery
service for fast and reliable
application and infrastructure updates
let's talk about code start code star is
a service design for developers where
they can quickly deploy build and
develop applications on AWS a double
scored star provides a unified user
interface enabling
to easily manage our software
development activities in one place with
AWS code star we can set up our entire
continuous delivery tool chain in
minutes allowing us to start releasing
codes faster and not only that aww Scott
star makes it easy for you or your a
whole team to work together securely
allowing you to easily manage access and
add owners contributors and viewers to
our project and not only that AWS code
star Roger comes with a project
management dashboard including an
integrated issue tracking capabilities
provided by a JIRA software with the ADA
blaze code star project dashboard we can
easily track progress across our entire
software development process from our
backlog of work items to team's recent
code deployments so on and so forth aww
Scott built on the other hand is an
cloud service that enables an IT
developer to build and test code with
continuous scale now here you pay only
for the build time that you have used
now code build is an fully managed
service that helps compiling a source
codes and run tests and produce software
packages that are ready to deploy
aw scope with AWS code build a we there
is no need for us to provision manage
and scale our own build service code
build scales continuously and process
and processes multiple bills
concurrently so our bills are not left
waiting in the queue because it's
processed concurrently let's talk about
security identity and compliance
services available in Amazon in general
the security identity and complaint
services in Amazon helps us to maintain
a secure environment in Amazon by
providing services for user
authentication for limiting the access
to certain set of users on the AWS
environment out of which I am or
Identity and Access Management it's a
product that enables us to manage access
to aww services and resources that
enables us to manage access to AWS
resources and services in a secure
fashion using I am we can create and
manage AWS users and
and use permissions to a love and deny
their access to AWS resources on the
other hand kms our key management
service is a managed service that makes
it easy for us to create and control the
encryption keys used to encrypt our data
and Cognito it lets us to add user
signup sign in and access control to our
web and mobile apps quickly and easily
and web or web application firewall
helps us to protect our web applications
from common web exploits that could
affect application availability that
could compromise security or consume
excessive resources and it gives us good
control over which traffic to allow or
block our applications by sort of
defining customizable web security rules
we can use graph to create custom rules
that block common attack patterns such
as SQL injections or cross-site
scripting and we can also create rules
that are designed for our specific
application out of all the four Identity
and Access Management it helps us to
control access to aw services and
resources for our users with the
Identity and Access Management I can
restrict user access or I can give a
user complete access to the environment
if it's an admin I can assign complete
access and if it is a user I can provide
some privileged access or less or
degraded or no access depending on the
role that the user plays in the
organization and kms is a service that
helps us to create and control the
encryption keys used to encrypt the data
and also we can use Hardware a security
model HSM to protect the security of our
data in the cloud also we can use
Hardware security model to protect the
security of the key itself and let's
talk about the management tools and
services available in Amazon management
tools and services it helps us to manage
monitor and automate all the resources
running in the AWS infrastructure
beginning with the cloud watch a service
which monitors the environment by
receiving logs and creating a dashboard
and sending alerts as needed and cloud
formation as service that a service
through which we can
deploy new environments using just
templates and auto-scaling a product
that lets us to handle the dynamic
traffic with ease by dynamically scaling
up and scaling down the environment as
needed and clout trail is another
product or another monitoring tool that
helps us to monitor or collect the logs
of all the API calls to our environment
and provides a searchable tool based on
keywords and timestamps let's talk about
cloud watch a bit more detail now cloud
watch is a monitoring service for AWS
with cloud watch we can collect we can
track the metrics we can collect and
monitor log files we can also enable
cloud watch to set alarms and
automatically react to changes in the
AWS environment cloud watch can also
monitor AWS resources such as ec2
instances DynamoDB tables Amazon RDS
instances as well as custom metrics
generated by your application and
services and any log files your
applications would generate now we can
use cloud watts to get a system-wide
visibility into resource utilization
application performance and operational
health we can use these insights to
react and keep your applications running
smoothly and cloud formation on the
other hand our provides a common
language for us to describe and
provision all the infrastructure
resources in our cloud environment now
cloud formation allows us to set up and
model all our AWS resources so that we
can spend less time in managing those
resources and more time on our
application our cloud formation is
really an infrastructure as a core
service where I can build an
infrastructure based on the portable
template I might be carrying alright in
this demo session we'll talk about how
to install Jenkins on Amazon Linux ec2
instance and before that let's talk
about what is Jenkins and what is the
purpose of it why it is used and all
that stuff now what is Jenkins Jenkins
is an open source automation server and
it provides a lot of inbuilt plugins for
deploying and automating any project in
short you know it's an continuous
integration server and it is used for
many purposes used for tasks that take
care of continuous deployment and
delivery and it provides these
advantages like the developer now will
not have to focus on fixing errors
because errors are automatically handled
by Jenkins and because of that it leads
to faster development environment
alright so how do we go about doing it
let's get started the first thing is to
go to our console and launch an ec2
instance actually let me walk you
through the steps through the PPT and
then I'll show it in a console so let me
first walk you through the steps in
installing a Jenkins server in this lab
we're gonna launch and VM or a virtual
application server to host our Jenkins
installation and then we are going to
deploy Jenkins on top of it and then
configure it as an build server and for
this we will need an AWS account to
begin with and then a bit of experience
in Jenkins and then some familiarity on
ec2 and how easy to gets connected to V
PC stuff like that so when we're all
done this is how the architect is gonna
look like you know users they get
connected to ec2 instance which is a
Jenkins server and then there are slaves
build slaves that can be monitored that
can be used in deployment by the Jenkins
server so let's see how it is done all
right so let's first launch a server let
it be an Amazon Linux instance I'm gonna
pick t2 micro because of the free
eligibility and because this is a lab
that should be more than enough and I'm
gonna keep this as default you know I'm
gonna stick with the default V PC and
I'm gonna keep all the settings as
defaults and then I'm not gonna add a
storage I'm going to keep the storage
limited with the root volume and then
for security group because we're gonna
access it through the internet I would
like port 80
in fact since this is a lap and bran man
and since I'll be tearing it down all
right after the lap is over we're gonna
use all IP or we're gonna use anywhere
all traffic anywhere view and launch and
I already have a keeper that I have
created if you're not familiar with
creating key pair launching ec2 instance
you might need to open some time or
watching the AWS ec2 video that would
help so I already have a key pair that's
attached to this account in this region
so I'm using that keeper to launch the
instance
right then that's my Jenkins server all
right so once that is installed let's
log into it since this being an now
Linux instance I'm going to use putty to
login and then use the key pair that we
have downloaded to login and the key
pair was right here
alright now I'm connected to it as first
thing we will have to install and the
Java environment I'm going to show some
commands towards end if you're planning
to do labs yourself you can use those
commands they will be very handy
in fact I can show it right now as we
speak
so these commands are to install java
environment
and it has two urchins as we speak and
I've chosen the latest version so I've
typed two and I've chosen the latest
version in installing Java environment
the second is to install Apache maven
let me show you some commands that's
used to install Apache maven and these
commands weary from no Linux version to
Linux version so if you're using a
different a Linux version just be sure
that you're using commands which are
respective to that particular version it
let's install Apache maven
you
looks like some of them are already
installed and it's wrong error for some
but anyway it's and it's considered and
successful installation and then let's
install Jenkins
and the commands to install Jenkins is
right here so these are to install
Jenkins and I mean to download the
software and install it and then start
the Jenkins and make sure the Jenkins
stays running even after a reboot so
let's run these commands
you
all right now Jenkins should be ready
all the Jenkins server is installed in
our ec2 instance and it is ready for us
to access and the default port is for
8080 so let me go to the URL or IP so
let me go to that and then try accessing
it using port 8080
they go so at the moment it's locked
it requires admin password to login and
the admin password is present in this
particular folder and this particular
file in the Linux instance so let me get
that
okay one moment looks like the admin
password is not present just give me one
quick moment okay it's just a formation
issue let me check the password in that
folder again with elevated permissions
they go there's my password
all right once we logged in we can
install all the suggested plugins now
that's gonna take some time to run and
install all the selected all the default
plugins needed to run a Jenkins server
all right it's done
now as next thing is gonna ask for the
admin username and password you can
choose as an existing administrator or
you can also create an another admin
user in this case I'm going to create
another admin user
all right so the Jenkins server is
installed we can use the similar but
slightly different procedure on the
genkan nodes or the slave servers to
make them Jenkins slave and no respond
to the bills that we push or to receive
the bills I receive the jobs that we
push through this Jenkins server so we
have built this a Jenkins server on
Amazon ec2 a similar and slightly
different procedures can be followed to
build Jenkins build servers that can
contact Jenkins server to receive jobs
and in a start working thank you for
watching I believe you enjoyed the
session I'll meet you in another session
thank you hi there if you liked this
video subscribe to the simple learn
YouTube channel
and click here to watch similar videos
Turner DUP and get certified click here